quand il a fait un costume je n'ai pas entendu
Rien d'étrange
ou peut-être oui petites jambes qui démangent un
que parce que l'acrylique je crois peut-être le
le pouvoir est entré dans ma balle
quand j'ai dormi là et ça te passe
mais c'est peut-être un pigeon magique
filaments le soir pour finir ensuite
le matin tu deviens un pyjama visible
magique en fait on dirait un pyjama peut-être
ça marche que si tu le mets longtemps alors
s'habiller en handicapé beaucoup de temps
maintenant quand tu as des tonalités normales non
je connais la chambre je ne sais pas
à propos de qui pas qui pas moi
craxi invisible et maintenant il doit aider
personnes en danger qui voulez-vous aider
je ne suis qu'un perdant